chicken manure often considered a waste
product can be a gold mine for gardeners
and Farmers looking to enhance their
soil's
fertility packed with essential
nutrients chicken manure can be
transformed into a powerful organic
fertilizer through a simple five-step
process step one collection and
preparation the first step in the
process of turning chicken manure into
fertilizer is the collection and
preparation phase collecting chicken
manure may sound straightforward but it
requires careful planning and
consideration of
hygiene start by regularly cleaning the
chicken Coupe or poultry house to ensure
a steady supply of fresh manure it's
crucial to collect a balanced mixture of
chicken manure including both droppings
and bedding materials Like Straw or wood
shavings the combination of these
elements creates an ideal environment
for beneficial microorganisms that play
a key role in the decomposition process
to prepare the collected manure for the
next steps create a compost pile by
layering the manure with other organic
materials such as leaves grass clippings
or kitchen
scraps this balanced mixture will help
achieve the optimal carbon to nitrogen
ratio promoting efficient
decomposition step two
composting composting is the heart of
the magic when it comes to Turning
chicken manure into a valuable
fertilizer the composting process breaks
down organic matter kills pathogens and
stabilizes nutrients transforms the raw
manure into a safe and nutrient-rich
material for plants to initiate the
composting process turn the pile
regularly to ensure proper eration the
compost pile should reach a temperature
between 130째 F to 150째 F 54째 C to 66째 C
to effectively kill harmful bacteria and
wheat seeds if the temperature drops
below this range turn the pile more
frequently to reintroduce oxygen
composting typically takes 2 to 4 months
depending on factors such as pile size
turning frequency and environmental
conditions regular monitoring and
adjustment are essential to ensure a
successful composting
process step three curing after the
composting process is complete the next
step is curing curing allows the compost
to stabilize further and ensures that
any remaining heat
dissipates this step is crucial to to
avoid potential damage to plant roots
when applying the compost to the soil
transfer the compost to a curing area
and let it rest for an additional 2 to 4
weeks during this period continue
monitoring the compost for any signs of
excessive heat or unpleasant odors if
the compost remains hot or smells
ammonal likee it indicates that the
curing process is not yet complete
properly cured chicken manure compost
should have a dark crumbly texture and a
rich earthy smell
once these characteristics are achieved
the compost is ready for the next step
in the transformation into a powerful
fertilizer step four mixing and
conditioning to maximize the benefits of
chicken manure fertilizer it's essential
to blend it with other organic materials
to create a well balanced and
nutrient-rich mixture mixing and
conditioning the composted chicken
manure with additional ingredients help
tailor the fertilizer to specific plant
needs consider adding organic amendments
like bone meal kelp meal or Rock
phosphate to enhance the nutrient
content of the
fertilizer these amendments contribute
Essential Elements such as phosphorus
and potassium complimenting the
nitrogen-rich chicken manure the goal is
to achieve a balanced fertilizer that
provides a diverse array of nutrients
for different stages of plant growth
experiment with different ratios and
amendments based on the specific needs
of your crops or garden step five
application the final step in the magic
of turning chicken manure into
fertilizer is the
application apply the finished chicken
manure fertilizer to your garden or Farm
by spreading it evenly over the soil
surface be sure to incorporate the
fertilizer into the soil using a rake or
tiller ensuring that nutrients are
distributed throughout the root Zone
chicken manura fertilizer is
particularly beneficial for vegetable
gardens fruit orchards and flowering
plants the rich nutrient content
promotes healthy plant growth improves
soil structure and enhances water
retention it's important to note that
while chicken manure fertilizer is a
fantastic organic option moderation is
key over application can lead to
nutrient imbalances and potential damage
to plants start with a conservative
amount and monitor plant response before
adjusting the application rate
transforming chicken manure into
fertilizer is a rewarding and
sustainable practice that not only helps
manage waste but but also contributes to
healthier soils and robust plant growth
by following the five-step magic outline
in this video from collection and
preparation to composting curing mixing
and application you can turn chicken
manure into a nutrient Powerhouse for
your garden or Farm as you embark on
this journey of sustainable agriculture
we encourage you to share your
experiences and
insights if you found this guide helpful
please like comment and subscribe to our
channel for more tips on organic
gardening sustainable farming and
eco-friendly living your engagement
helps us continue to provide valuable
information and Inspire others to join
the movement towards a Greener and
healthier Planet happy
gardening